I've had a lot of success in my career
by boiling things down to their
fundamentals I'm a big believer in first
principles of like in physics and in you
know I think you can apply that to most
things so whenever I'm dealing with a
problem I just boil things down to what
are the fundamentals of this and so with
filmmaking when you really think about
it the fundamentals are you know you
need a camera and you need a setting and
then you need actors to inhabit that
setting and that's really all you need
maybe you don't even actually need a
script because the the actors could
improv everything I recommend a script
but technically you don't need it you
just need to deal with those other
foundations and then anything else that
you bring is something that you bring
this tailor-made for your individual
project and so when you start to think
about it that way it seems a lot less
daunting so for me I had to knock down
before I did anything else those those
three foundations and so the first one
was camera so you know I'm a technology
person obviously you know writing
science fiction and I'm a big believer
in Moore's law for sure I mean you don't
believe in Moore's Law it's just a fact
that information technology is doubling
in price performance every 12 to 18
months so that's pretty exciting
especially in this new era of digital
filmmaking but I had worked with a
couple of small production companies
here in Vancouver and they were looking
at using the the tools that professional
productions these days usually use for
digital filmmaking and you know so they
were looking into Reds and Ariel exes
and I was astounded by the price of the
technology and how cumbersome the
technology was as well and that you know
you couldn't really own these cameras
they were so expensive that it was cost
prohibitive so you had to just rent them
and to me that seemed that it would
cause an issue when it came to becoming
with the cameras and then you end up
needing a director photography so I was
interested in whether or not I could
actually own one of the cameras and I
started to look into them to learn as
much as I could about them and you know
as I was looking at comparisons between
a lot of digital film cameras that are
really professional-grade and what it
kept seeing in the comment sections of
these you know reviews and comparisons
was a lot of people talking about this
Blackmagic camera which I'd never heard
of before and he looked into it myself
and saw there was a huge difference in
price I mean it's laughable Blackmagic
cameras can be you know one-fiftieth or
one-hundredth in some cases the price of
these other cameras with similar sized
sensors so you know I was very intrigued
by this because it seemed as though
there was one company that had already
it was like a company from the future
you know they they had already made this
technology affordable on it was
something that the the masses could get
their hands on but of course you wonder
is it too good to be true so my wife and
I actually started to do a lot of
research specifically on the different
models of Blackmagic cameras and we were
looking at Vimeo and we were looking at
Shane Hurlbut is really good he's a
director of photography that looks into
all these different types of cameras and
and we saw that the camera was holding
up really well against the best cameras
out there so we had the potential of
actually you know buying a camera
outright especially for us we were very
interested in the Blackmagic pocket
Cinema Camera because it was less than a
thousand dollars about the same as a
rental fee for one of these other
cameras and I if I could own it outright
I could test it I could become
proficient with it myself I could try
out different lenses and different
filters and different stabilizing
equipment and that's exactly what I did
we got the Blackmagic and you know after
watching lots of reviews for it and we
tried some different lenses and we did
some tests
lucky for us there was another lens that
I just come on the market another
affordable great lens and this was the
Sigma 18 and 35 millimeter lens this one
did you know the wider stuff just as
well as the RO Kinyon did but it didn't
have that fish I look on the close-up so
we had the we had the tools we needed at
that point the next thing we looked into
was stabilization we we grabbed a a
glide cam which was really important we
used it a lot we have a slider so when
you look at the proof of concept and you
see those gorgeous slider shots that's
the result of having that slider and I
did have a body mount that we used a
little bit and then also two tripods to
both hold the slider up and then also
just for our fixed camera position shots
when we were getting you know medium
range close-ups and we also had a meta
bones smart lens adapter that we put on
the black magic which is fantastic
because that allowed us to look let in a
lot of light
and it made us really lean and mean on
our shooting day because we we didn't
require any lighting everything was lit
by these gorgeous floor-to-ceiling
windows the the setting was just an
incredible setting I I liked it more
than I don't think I've ever done
because it was just was such a small
group of people but all of us were so
passionate about it and but we kind of
set out to do the impossible to film the
short film in three hours and we were
all excited
some of us haven't gotten any sleep and
and we got there and we just made
something incredible anyway even though
it seemed to be against all odds when I
first heard David's concept of his way
of filmmaking
I wouldn't say was impossible I would
put it as a different approach it was
really new it was so safe but it was get
out get a film idea get equipment get
location shoot and pull it for doctor
validated but that was just
so not so easy right just saying it
that's so easy I didn't know he was
gonna I was like saying impossible it
was just different just was a new unique
approach of to filmmaking and if I think
about future filmmaking I think this is
the best approach for new or independent
or young filmmakers who wouldn't have
the same butt